yoel Roth who was the the like top guy
of their moderation was actively posting
about children consenting and other
creepy things like this that people have
basically pointed to saying the dude was
obsessed with gay porn he was posting
nonsense about it he had he had a dummy
account a sock puppet where he would
post lewd things apparently and his Elon
Musk called him out saying his his was
it his PhD thesis was arguing for like
minors to have access to adult sex apps
the the PHD thesis thing I read some
stuff about it and the thing that I read
yeah I don't think that he was arguing
for underage people to be encouraged to
use those things the way that
people are saying that he was arguing he
was saying look
kids get into Apps kids get porn kids
get these things so trying to say that
they trying to just keep them off
doesn't work now I don't think he's
right and I disagree with the point that
he was trying to make but I don't think
that in his PhD thesis he was intending
to say that we should but here here's
what was this topic it was he he did
like uh a PhD thesis on the use of
grinder and stuff like that
I'm not going to come out and say that
the dude actively said children should
be hooking up with adults on these apps
the issue is that he said kids are
already on these apps therefore we need
to consider that there needs to be
something for them to use blah blah blah
and I'm like yeah that's called that's
the erosion
that's how we get from if if you went
back in time 14 years and said if you
know this this this this bill passes or
if gay marriage is legalized they're
going to be teaching kids how to have
gay sex in schools they'd laugh at you I
mean that was a common talking point now
project Veritas releases a video showing
the dean in a Chicago school was at
Francis W Parker talking about how he
was there as he brought someone into
hand around adult toys and that's a
private school right private school and
when I talk to these leftists they're
like well they're just teaching sex ed
but you know queer sex head and I'm like
and there it is they said it wouldn't
happen of course it happened if YOLO
Roth is going to come out and say look
they're already on these apps this he's
basically saying the solution isn't to
enforce the policies saying miners
shouldn't be using adult hookup apps
he's saying well you know they're
already there so uh and this is the
issue here and I really want to bring
this up because you add that to the fact
that when he was running things at
Twitter which essentially he was he was
calling all the shots he was deciding
who was going to be banned and not
banned there was children that came to
the company and said hey yes my photos
were uploaded when I was a child of me
uh committing uh you know adult actions
please take it off Twitter said no it
doesn't violate our policy he kept it on
the platform as it was on their servers
as they were meeting with the FBI weekly
you're supposed to report those things
to the FBI immediately they were sitting
and chatting with the FBI almost once a
week if not even more and you add this
to the fact of if you want to go down
the rabbit hole we can uh and Jack
posobic actually kind of pointed at this
and hinted at this too there is a
possibility that the feds caught
somebody let's just say someone like
yoel in in a precarious situation or on
our website and potentially said hey uh
we have you on this particular charge
you have to act on our B hats unless we
expose you and making you go to jail
that's one possibility that could be
happening here I'm not saying that
there's actual proof here but with the
way that the FBI has been operating
within the United States it's fair to
speculate that this is a major
possibility here okay there is literally
nothing that I would put past the FBI I
have absolutely zero confidence in the
FBI as an organization uh and I think
it's corrupt as as it gets that being
said I don don't know that there is any
kind of evidence that makes me think
that they have something on UL that
would make uol
dis ignore child porno what about
Jeffrey Jeffrey Epstein but he was he
was I'm not saying that he wasn't I'm
saying no I don't know that I know the
FBI has anything on so my question is
then why why were they ignoring it I
just think ul's kind of a bad person
but there but there was more than just
him there's a bunch of people that they
knew it was happening and the outright
were like nah uh I I can't even
speculate I can't even I got I gotta
wrap my head around how you justify
leaving that kind of stuff up without
taking like and not taking it maybe it
was like I can't like you complained or
or person a complained but they couldn't
confirm that it was actually person a no
families and children came to them and
said hey this is me this is on my
platform like yeah this is fine this is
totally cool and and when we look at
when we look at the FBI this this is not
something that's uncommon this is
something that is common uh children and
and other people were coming to them in
the 90s saying hey there's this guy with
the Private Island who's doing these
things to us they ignored them for over
30. we know the FBI ignored uh the uh
Simone bile or I think is that her name
the Olympic Athlete the Simone biles was
her name yeah and there was there was
other people that and that other Gym
trainer yeah they went to the FBI and
the FBI didn't do anything
so yeah I like I said I my faith in the
FBI is almost not well non-existent I
have I have no use for it and I'm you
know I'm the guy that wants to get rid
of
cabinet level bureaucracies abolish
cabinet level bureaucracies get rid of
them a lot of them so I want to get that
out I don't think uh he needs dirt on
yoel to get him to cooperate I think FBI
probably reached out and he went whoa
yeah cool the FBI yeah I think he was
like sick let's do this there's the
messages yeah in the in the Twitter
files where he's like definitely not
meeting with the FBI right now about
Trump there was there was no need to
encourage anyone at Twitter to get them
to to behave in a hostile manner manner
towards Donald Trump or anyone else that
they possibly would conceive of as a
deplorable I have one big regret from
that interview I did with Joe Rogan and
it's that it did not occur to me to ask
Vijaya and Jack if they had been in
communication with the government at all
and that was so I looked back on that so
stupid because it should have been
question number one okay you're you're
Banning people is the government in any
way involved in directing you or
advising you or requesting you take
anybody down didn't even occur to me to
ask that because we weren't you know
it's it's the context the time at the
time the big question was Private
companies and what they were doing but
uh now I look back like just just to get
out of the way like just as a formality
government are they involved in any way
well they probably would have lied you
know that would have been good though
get them on on tape lying or uh or
telling the truth on that one I think
you know in regard to Joel before we get
too far away from this uh dissertation
that he did this PhD thesis I think it's
called Gay data is the name of it um I
think what he was indicating is not he's
saying like you were mentioning Tim
earlier that we have grinder and uh kids
are getting on Grindr and that's a
problem how do we solve it I think what
he was suggesting is that we have an app
for miners like a grinder for miners or
a Tinder for miners but where that falls
short is like how the hell can you stop
adults from getting in there I mean
that's only marginally horrifying
but also I'm pretty sure he talks about
how Grindr isn't actually a dating app
it's a hookup app how these guys aren't
meeting to find love they're geolocating
each other for hookups that's what I was
reading about I don't want to disparage
any of these guys who may be trying to
find love I don't know I don't I I don't
know about you know
I don't know I I don't know how it works
but I the idea of children being on
Tinder I like I've I've got a Tinder
account and it's a mess out there it is
it is craziness and and so no right this
is this is the point recommending but
they're already using these apps because
they want to meet people right we should
make apps for them no no no that's how
they move the line they keep moving the
line they're like well kids are gonna
yeah kids are gonna date when a kid's in
high school he hangs out his high school
kids he hangs out his classmates and the
kids the the chick from Seventh Pierce
got Jim and he's got home a room
whatever they meet they don't go on
dating apps and then just start swiping
right on random people in their
neighborhood it's bad enough adults to
do it yeah that there's no I can't I
can't come up with the justification to
give children that's that's the erosion
look I'm not giving this guy yo all the
benefit of the doubt at all because the
Dude literally was the head of this
stuff when exploitation was on Twitter
and they weren't taking it down so my
assumption is he must enjoy it so I'm
not going to give him the benefit of the
doubt but I I I look at what's what's
going on and you get people who say
something like oh a drag show isn't
sexualized and I'm like they literally
take their clothes off do the splits
drop low twerk in front of people like
it is it is to cut to say that a drag
show is not sexualized I again that's
another thing where it's like all right
well I can't I can't seriously engage in
a conversation with you because we
you're not gonna come from a a place of
honesty like but then there's no there's
there's no moving forward with solving
these issues it's such a black pill such
a black pill take and if you look at
well hold on like look I got because no
moving forward like if you're actually
saying no moving forward no more head
forward is real bad have you had a
conversation when they left us about
this stuff and see them on Twitter all
the time I know I've got things there
are friends of mine that we've had calm
conversations there's a friend of mine
on Facebook people you don't understand
this because the leftists refuse to
acknowledge it okay Luke and I were both
at occupied Wall Street three thousand
people follow me they're all leftist
occupied people
when the death threats came in I get a
message from a few people they're on the
left and they're like look man I know we
disagree I disagree with the things
you've said but this is wrong we
obviously don't want the same say
regular people don't want it these are
the kind of messages I get I then ask
them I'm like here's the video from
Project veritas this teacher was giving
these things to kids and the response
from them is this is acceptable and fine
because it's sex ed for kids on queer
issues and I'm like you see that's it
right there
look if you go
if if you want to justify going to like
six sixth graders 12 year olds and being
like here is anatomy and biology design
and you don't explain to them how to do
anything you just say like you know
here's like what what happened with me
when I was in grade school is they
brought the boys in one room all the
girls another room he said here's the
anatomy here's how it works here's sex
ed and that was it what they're doing
now is under the guise of LGBT plus
curriculum handing children butt plugs
and and other adult toys and explaining
spinning and lubing okay that is well
beyond sex ed that is something
different they're not explaining them
how to reproduce or how the organs work
is sex and sex ed used to mean yes sex
ed used to be anatomy and and Technical
uh understanding of of the function and
operation as opposed to now it seems
like these classes are more about
classes and the dangers and about well I
I remember they told you hey you could
get these diseases you could get
pregnant this way there wasn't a
conversation and and like a step-by-step
program on how to have butt sex right I
don't remember that in high school but
the realism is that the sex that is
happening on the internet on porn
websites whether we wanted to or not any
kid that wants to find it it is which is
readily available which is free and it's
out there which should make people
question why is it so readily available
why is it so why is there so much out
there why is this so free I want to take
it I want to take it down a bigger level
I want to say one thing to that even
even if you're right that doesn't mean
that the state is in a position to say
well your kids probably have cell phones
or their friends have cell phones that
can access pornography on the internet
so because of that we're just going to
go ahead and step on in here and insert
ourselves into this aspect of your
child's life they don't have any right
to do that just because there's
pornography on the internet and to make
that lead like that's that's not a
logical leap that says oh because
there's porn then the state must do this
thing that's that's that is not an
argument for it in my opinion at all
right parents need to make sure their
kids aren't going on these websites
don't have phones but this is a problem
with more fatherless homes with more
parents not being able to be there for
their children it's less for a lot of
these devices to raise them and if you
look at the devices that that a lot of
the children surround themselves with
whether it's Instagram or Tick Tock
what's on those platforms what is
suggested to you what is on the explore
options for a lot of these uh apps and
applications what is is it it's it's
it's people shaking their asses it it
it's it's big booty hoes the thumbnails
on Instagram it's like always some kind
of subject suggestive thing I think it
was Alex Stein I think it was him you
pull up Instagram and there was a video
of like a woman on her knees sticking
her tongue out and it was like then when
you play the video it was her like
kneeling down and tying his shoe or
something yeah so to take it to another
level right so we know that FBI plays a
key critical role on big Tech social
media platforms uh you know deciding who
stays deciding what gets played what
gets talked about what gets uh you know
trending in the algorithm I would even
go as far as to say their involvement
revolves around all those issues uh
especially when it came to the Banning
of people uh with all these companies
working in unison so I think that it
even goes even further with them
dictating a lot of this content and
providing a lot of this over
sexualization of children which is
essentially destroying people's uh uh
childhoods and robbing them of their
innocence but also creating a situation
where they're less likely to to have
families in the future essentially
destroying a strong family unit
essentially making individuals that are
more easily to be conquered and more
easily to be enslaved with this larger
social engineering which is happening on
all these apps I heard in um as a
pushback to the people that are
complaining about drag shows a lot of
people are then you might say the left
people on the left the counter is like
well what about beauty pageants what
about seven-year-olds with makeup I
think so too yeah that red makeup and
lipstick is supposed to simulate a woman
that's being is ready to give like
happily Jordan Peterson talked about
this extensively and he made a lot of
good references and points especially
when it came to a lot of the makeup that
is suggestive of of procreation let's
just be honest here let's just be real
with each other so so putting that on
small children putting them in heels is
something that that again should be
pushed back on even if it's those beauty
pageants absolutely push push back on
them immediately because they're just
strange I never I never understood why
they're doing this and it it's just as
bad we've moved on so fast from this is
not happening this is is not happening
to this is happening so what it's okay
yeah it's not happening okay it's not
happening but if it was then it would be
fine uh now it's happening it's a good
thing thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time